I promise you this is the flakiest  creamiest easiest chicken pot pie recipe  you'll ever try in your entire life so  you're going to start with everything  that I've listed on the screen and  you're going to saute it all up but  honestly you can use whatever veggies  you have on hand then you're going to  take herbs butter and flour and you're  going to go ahead and toss in your  liquids before adding in your chicken  and Seasonings and then you're going to  let it cook Slow and Low that's the  secret you want a nice thick and creamy  texture then you're going to add puff  pastry to your pan and fill your chicken  pot pie mixture all the way to the top  before egg washing and letting it cook  until it's nice and golden brown this is  a super easy recipe and it's super tasty  try it out